des guirlandes lumineuses qui prennent
feu un bouchon de champagne qui
explosent des boules de noël qui se
brise chaque année le service d'urgence
mains de l'hôpital privé du mont garder
à aubergenville enregistre un pic de
fréquentation à la fin de l'année on a
beaucoup d'urgences ont entre 12 à 15
urgences par jour
avec essentiellement de l'accident
domestique pendant la période des fêtes
des couteaux à huîtres et des infections
aussi sur des plaies d'un couteau à
huîtres l'équipe est composée de six
chirurgien spécialiste de la main à
l'épaule qui assure en moyenne 23 mille
interventions chirurgicales par an et le
31 janvier les accidents les plus
courants sont causés par des pétards ou
des tirs de mortiers pour éviter de se
blesser il faut faire attention il faut
mettre des gants quand on jardine il
faut éviter la manipulation de pétards
artisanaux et de mortiers pour faire des
feux d'artifice
dans la rue le 31 au soir si vous êtes
victime d'un accident au niveau de la
main le premier réflexe est d'appeler le
18 le numéro d'urgence des pompiers puis
d'envelopper sa main dans un linge
propre mais surtout prudents avec le
couteau à huîtres